[موسيقى]
معكم فاديه حداد مصممه ازياء لبنانيه انا
اليوم راح اعطيكم كم ببس لتوفر عليكم وقت
ومصاري وتلكم مبينين بمظهر جدا
انق اول تب لليوم تستعملوا المخيطه الربر
تلفو على الزر وتفوتو بالعروه بترجعوا
بتطلعو وتحطوها بالزر وهيك بصير الجينز عم
بياخذ وبيعطي بتحطوا البلوزه شوي طلعوها
لبره ل تخبوا مظهر هال
الاستك ثاني لليوم قشره الموزه ما تكب اذا
عندك بحه على القميص بتفركي فيها الموزه
على البحه بيتفك الكمك برودكت يلي على
القميص وهيك بصير فيك تبيها وتحطيها
بالغساله
بتصير بتنظف وبترجع مثل ما
كانت الالث ليون هو اذا كان عندكم الجينز
واسع وبدكم تضيقوا شو بتعملوا بتبل خصر
الجينز بالماي بتحطوا عليه سيشوار بحراره
كثير عاليه بتضل تحطوه لحتى ينشف الينز
وهيك الجينز بيصغر عليكم بصير فيكم تلبسوه
متحي رابع تب الك اليوم ما الك جلاده ايسه
وما عندك وقت عجبك بنطلون بتلفيه على
رابتك اذا سكر على رابتك يعني هيدا هو
ياسك خم ستب لليوم بدك التيشرت تبعك مديق
على الغسيل رشيها سبراي للشعر كلها وتريها
شوي وبعدين ارجعي حطيها
[موسيقى]
بالغساله سادس يب لليوم حطي سكربيت
بالثلاجه نص ساعه قبل ما تلبسيها ليش
سكربينه مسقعه وشرك سخنه سكربينه راح تاخذ
فورمه ارجلك وهيك راح فيك تكملي سهرتك انت
ومرتاحه